Tylar forgive me for this angle I'm just
gonna say it
um you know you are incredibly
good-looking as you as so are you Pascal
you both could be brothers but we're
directing this when the Tyler but I'm
wondering do people ever think that
maybe he's pretty but he can't act until
they see you act and then they know he
can Wow he's got a huge range of emotion
but when you first go somewhere because
especially la is very visual
do you think that sometimes they feel
like oh this guy is really good-looking
but you know what I don't know if we're
gonna be able to cast him well I mean
personally I'm flattered did you say so
but yeah absolutely I think that you
know this is a business of aesthetics so
it certainly certainly as a factor but
um but to your question absolutely I
think I think it's one of the things
that I I tried to to capitalize on as
much as possible which is the under
expectation that can often go with the
way that we stereotype someone based
upon their looks so you know for me I
kind of use it to my advantage I like
I'm someone who prized myself on
craftsmanship I really take this job
very seriously I take the work very
seriously it's very near and dear to my
heart and the result is is that you know
I kind of want you to to count me out a
little bit at certain times really so
you almost want to surprise people a
little bit that like wow I didn't think
he could go there absolutely if you
watch the film you definitely see that
but but at first glance maybe they would
just think oh wow this guy's probably a
model right how do you how do you do
that that's interesting so you kind of
almost catch them off guard a little bit
yeah but at the same time you know you
watch like the Avengers for example
everyone is super good-looking and no
one say anything about it like oh my god
they're so beautiful no they all in the
story about the concept and they are
involved in it but when sometimes it's
them about independent film it's kind of
easier to judge like I is just beautiful
people no it's not beautiful people you
want people who look like stars you want
people who look you don't want to
something something that looks kind of
cheap or independent you want them to
look like sorry
look at this beautiful pretty face he
look like a star and that's why I casted
him in the film
you